if we rely on the magic pills and the
Magic Bullets and the magic injections
we're never going to get at peace with
ourselves and develop that self-efficacy
that's critical for everything now well
into the new year we've kind of reached
that point where most people's
resolutions have already begun to falter
particularly our habits around food this
willpower approach doesn't have a
neuroscientific backing neuroscientist
and addiction psychiatrist Dr Jud Brewer
back for his third appearance on the
show has answers that I think will
profoundly change everything you thought
you knew about how to lose weight and
how to eat to thrive we're engineering
food to manipulate a specific thing it's
not about nutrition it's not about
Optimal Health it's about consuming most
diets fail most of the time this episode
is a must listen and jud's latest book
The Hunger habit is a must read instead
of like trying to fight your craving
especially when it's all consuming we
can't fight it so what can we do
instead today's episode is brought to
you by the awesome organizations that
make this show
[Music]
[Applause]
possible cool Jud so great to see you
good to see you nice to have you in the
studio I'm very excited to talk to you
today previously we have gone in depth
into your backstory your credentials Etc
we're not going to do that today but I
do think it would be worthwhile for you
to just briefly give us a glimpse of
your background and your experience
leading up to this point of tackling
hunger and food which is a universal
subject that we all contend with yeah
yeah well the the short version of it is
you know I did mdphd program was very
interested in like how stress affects
the immune system and things like that
was working in Mouse models and then
shifted my career when when I decided to
become a psychiatrist last thing I
thought I was going to do but I started
meditating at the beginning of medical
school and got into that and was
starting to realize how little I knew
about my own mind and so when I finished
my mdphd I shifted my career to really
like going wholeheartedly into like
neuroscience clinical trials and
learning all that stuff and there was a
big deficit in and you know this um in
addiction treatment right and so this is
in the early ASDS so started just
kicking the tires on mindfulness
training to see if it could help like
first with cocaine and alcohol use
disorder and found that it was as good
as CBT then started doing smoking
sensation studies got like five times
the quit rates of gold standard
treatment with mindfulness I was like oh
there's something here and then we
started doing some of the Neuroscience
like the neuroimaging and looking to see
what was going on but as we were
starting to try to figure out how to
scale some of this cuz as a clinician I
want to see what's going to work for my
patients and what's going to actually
get out there and help other patients I
was doing some work with like developing
this app for smoking Sensations craving
a quit app and somebody that was pilot
testing it they were saying it's
changing my eating habits and at first I
blew that Comet off cuz most people gain
about 15 pounds when they quit smoking
you know the stimulant effects gone and
all this and they also replac that oral
fixation with food but they said
something that made me look sideways
where I was like they said hey you know
it's actually I'm cutting down on my
snacking using these practices and I
said you did the Double Take and said
say more about that and they said you
know I'm using some of these principles
and practices that you help people with
smoking Cravings with to curve my eating
Cravings I never thought about working
in the eating space but it put my mind
on the track of like well could we help
with this clinical obesity epidemic
because you know medical school I
learned this calories in calories out
the formula is still correct but they
never taught us the how they just assume
that you know you are the doctor and
your patient's going to listen and
they're just magically going to be able
to use their willpower or whatever to
cut down on on you know snacking or
overeating or eating junk food and
clinically I didn't see that you know I
was like wait what did I miss here you
know that's kind of where what brings us
to this work with eating is that I
started approaching it from the lens of
habit change instead of like the
willpower approach and that's when
things got really really interesting so
that's the long and short of it yeah I
feel like it's a natural progression of
all the work that you've done the work
that you've done in the field of anxiety
and stress smoking sensation habit
formation and habit change in the
context of addictions and and compulsive
behaviors expanding the aperture beyond
the 12-step model or the disease model
in general
to bring mindfulness practices
meditation awareness into our behaviors
to kind of connect us more deeply with
ourselves and and allow us to in a
non-judgmental way understand and take
inventory of of how we behave as a
baseline to then shift those behaviors
and you've had great success with that
so it's not a surprise that you would
now focus on our eating habits because I
think everybody can relate to having
some kind of compulsivity around certain
types of foods or or struggling to
maintain their weight I mean this is a
universal thing so it's very natural I
know you shared before the podcast even
started that it hadn't occurred to you
to kind of write a book about this but
to me it feels a very natural
progression of your career yeah well our
scientific theat are really strong and I
think so many people don't still this
blows my mind they still don't connect
the mind and the body and to me they're
Inseparable my sense is from how you
operate you you see that as well it's
like you can't approach one without the
other and so many people are just trying
to divorce the head from the body and
just treat the you know clinical obesity
or whatever as a physical thing doesn't
work that way you got to treat the whole
human right the thesis being like if you
want to change your relationship with
food you have to change yourself yes you
know nobody wants to hear that though
they want the Quick Fix You have the
21-day program we're going to talk about
that but uh yeah that's the kind of bad
news baked into this which is actually
good news because you end up getting
much more than you bargain for if you
decide to sign up for this adventure
yeah there's no going back once you
start seeing how your brain works so
let's start out with some real basic
stuff like what is a habit like from a
neuroscientific perspective like how do
you define what a habit is before we
even get into food yeah so you can think
of simple definition of a habit is
basically something we do a
automatically and habits are set up to
help us not have to expend energy
learning new things every day you know
imagine wake up in the morning and you
fall out of bed because you forgot how
to walk you know you couldn't put your
clothes on you had to relearn that had
to relearn how to make coffee you know
you can imagine we wouldn't make it past
breakfast before needing another nap
yeah so it's really about this set and
forget where we like set these habits we
forget about the details and that helps
us do things automatically that really
are really helpful so that we can have
that cognitive energy to learn new
things every day and is there a specific
area in the brain where this
functionality is centered there are a
number of networks that work together
around this and so one of the most
studied networks is this dopaminergic
reward based Network you know it's
involves the vental tegmental area the
nucleic humins and this dopamine
spritzing that's really set up to help
us form memory memories and so if you
think of this from an evolutionary
perspective it's about you know being
able to remember things like context
dependent memory formation so on the
Savannah when there weren't
refrigerators and people had to remember
where food was any habit Loop has three
elements right a trigger behavior and a
result so let's say they're they go on
the Savannah they find food there's the
trigger they eat the food there's the
behavior and then they've get this
dopamine Spritz in their brain actually
their stomach and their mouth there's
several places where dopamine is going
to send off firing for that dopamine
fire in the brain because it's that
important to be able to get that signal
across and that says hey remember this
remember the context remember the food
Etc and that's you know in modern day we
call that positive reinforcement right
isn't part of that dopa manic pathway
rooted in anticipation it's not as much
about the payoff when you actually
indulge in the behavior and get the
reward or the result it is the emotional
experience or the hormonal experience
anticipating that reward in the pursuit
of that behavior I'm glad you asked that
question cuz it's a both and where
before we know that something's
rewarding we have to learn it so this is
where surprise comes in so when we're
surprised oh I didn't know that was
tasty we get a dopamine Spritz that says
hey remember this but then that dopamine
firing shifts to anticipating it so when
we have a memory of that thing we get
this dopamine firing not when we're
there but before we're there that says
go get it and it's this itchy urgy
quality that says go do something
because that's adaptive right it says
you know if you're hungry don't just sit
in the cave go get the food right so it
shifts from this firing of like I
learned something to the firing that
you're talking about which is
anticipating getting it so obviously
there's an evolutionary incentive to
develop habits as a race to perpetuate
the species and all of that um I'm
curious around the receptivity to new
habits obviously there's this adage like
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
from a neuroscience perspective I
suspect that there's more myth than than
truth in that yeah um but we also know
that we can learn languages or learn how
to play instruments and do certain
things at a young age much with much
more facility than we can when we're
older so when you're thinking about
habits or talking about habits what's
going on in the brain with respect to
receptivity as we get older is it harder
to break and form new habits or is it
really not that much different so the
good news is we can break and form new
habits we have to be able to adapt in an
everchanging environment I don't know if
there's a little bit of a trail off as
we age there it's a good question I
don't know if there's a super clear
answer on that people used to think that
the brain doesn't change and then they
learn that you actually get neurogenesis
in the hippocampus you know so they're
they're new things that are coming out
all the time pragmatically speaking one
thing that our brain we do know is that
our brains are these prediction machines
where they're always trying to predict
the future you know it's called
predictive processing and what they're
trying to do is get certainty trying to
get as much certainty as possible and so
that certainty is that old dog having
the old tricks and those tricks work for
the old dog and so the dog says why
should I change this this is working for
me and the longer it's worked this is
our comfort zone basically the more it
feels comfortable because our brain is
saying don't change I know this works so
that that feeling of the comfort zone is
really our brain saying hey it works and
there's you in Neuroscience they call
this um the exploit explore tradeoff
where you know if you get a food source
and it's a really good food source you
want to stay there and exploit that as
compared to like going off and trying to
find another one because you might not
find it and then you're you know you're
missing out but the problem is if you
state a food source and it dries up
you've got to get that urge to go
explore so when in our modern day when
we can kind of set things more and more
and more to like be constantly working
for us you know it's like oh I eat the
same food every week and I sit on the
couch and watch this television show or
or whatever the more that becomes
ingrained and that that's where that
feeling of the challenge of change comes
in but old dogs you know like when the
television shows start you know start
drying up so to speak
then suddenly we get anti to find new on
so it's there yeah in the case of true
compulsivity or legitimate addictive
behavior patterns what comes along for
the ride with that is a whole you know
sort of set of baggage around denial and
like refusing to believe that this is no
longer working for you and all the kind
of rationalization You know despite you
know external evidence telling you like
this habit is not in service of your
well-being uh the recalcitrance of of
the human mind to accept that is you
know profound yeah it's true and and
with addiction especially with that big
manipulation of the dopamine system
that's where we we fool ourselves you
know and it's like do this again and
that's really that wow that was a big
dopamine hit and so I think we get you
know like you're saying we fool
ourselves because our brain is saying no
that was a big dopamine hit that should
be working and so we're going to go
through the den the um we're going to
ignore things we're going to do all
these things where it's like no keep
doing this keep doing this until you
know until we hit rock botom so as we
move into a conversation around how all
of these are applicable in the context
of of nutrition you know it's worth
noting or spending a few minutes
acknowledging the fact that our our kind
of unhealthy relationship and habits
around food are really a function of the
modern Western world and the food
environment in which we find ourselves
like this book and your work and
everything that's going into thinking
about how to reframe our habits around
food would just be an irrelevant
non-issue 200 years ago like this is a
modern problem that we've created for
ourselves yeah absolutely I mean if you
look at the amount of energy time money
that's spent on engineering food you
know that's very different than food
sources evolving over you know millions
of years right those have perfected
themselves and here we're engineering
food to manipulate a specific thing it's
not about nutrition it's not about
Optimal Health it's about consuming like
full stop it's all about getting people
to consume more you know to get you to
be as mindless as possible to divorce
you as thoroughly as imaginable from you
know what's in your best interest you
know when the term food addiction comes
up like is food addiction a real thing I
guess it depends on how you define the
term addiction yeah but how do you think
about that well it's certainly a debate
in the scientific community and the
medical community people can debate all
they want from a pragmatic standpoint
you know as a clinici I'm looking at and
I I learned this really simple
definition of addiction in residency
that I absolutely love which is just
continued use despite adverse
consequences and so if you look at it
that way it's not just the cocaine the
cigarette the alcohol it's social media
you know like somebody's texting while
driving continu just despite ERS
consequence is more dangerous than drunk
driving in some studies right so food in
the same way where people are overc
consuming you know there's a continued
use and their adverse consequences when
it comes to their health you know I'm
thinking of clinical obesity here and I
want to make a distinction here in the
modern science if you look at the BMI uh
it's not a great marker of obesity and
so I think it's really important the
debates are helping here where us where
we're starting to distinguish like hey
somebody could be f fat and healthy and
then you know the society says hey
you're fat you know there's something
you know all the fat shaming that comes
with that I think we need to stop that
we need to have that conversation and
show people hey it may not be the
societal norm and that's the problem
with Society not with the
people but that's different from
Clinical obesity and so this BMI measure
is a really quick and dirty and easy and
cheap measure you know height and weight
you're done but it it's not good at
differentiating lean muscle Mass versus
um versus fat especially if you look at
trunk obesity and and like the visceral
obesity that seem to be more dangerous
than other types of fat so I'm here I'm
talking about clinical obesity as
compared to just OB I shouldn't say just
obesity but there's a differentiation
there right so it's January
everybody's writing out their New Year's
resolutions their endeavoring to do all
sorts of things but at the top of that
list generally is people want to lose
weight they want to to get a little bit
more fit um they go on a diet uh but you
have this whole thesis around why diets
don't work so State your case good
doctor I'd be happy to and you don't
have to go much farther than asking
anybody that's been on a diet how well
it's worked for them you know if you
look back historically probably the the
largest diet movement in the last
century in the in the US at least was
around Weight Watchers you know formed
in
1963 interestingly same year that LS had
their famous potato chip challenge bet
you can't eat just one right because
they're this is about the designing of
over consumption so if you look at the
dieting industry there's new
nomenclature around this called yo-yo
dieting right and so over and over and
over again it's been shown that whatever
diet somebody goes on whether you know
calory restriction this or that diet if
people are approaching it the standard
way which is just use your willpower
more likely than not they're going to
loosen weight and they're going to
regain it and sometimes they'll regain
more you know they get rebound effects
and so we haven't seen consistent weight
loss in any major clinical trial that
really shows like hey this is going to
do it long term through a calorie
restriction standpoint yeah it's very
interesting if you if you were to graph
the kind of GDP of the weight loss
industry over the last 50 or 60 years
you'd get this upward like it's just a
massive bus with efficacy it would just
be like an X you know like the bigger
the industry gets the less efficacious
the results and we continue to get more
obese and more unhealthy and I would add
to that that it's a great business model
because they can say look the formula is
correct if you make sure you burn more
calories than you take in you're going
to lose weight and so there must be
something wrong with you if you can't
follow the formula and so they shame
people maybe not explicitly but people
implicitly feel like there's something
wrong with them oh it's such a simple
formula I should be able to follow
what's wrong with me the problem is that
they're relying on something from a
neuroscience standpoint is more myth
than muscle like this willpower approach
doesn't have neuroscientific
backing right so that's the core kind of
key premise at the root of every diet
which is you're going to have to rely on
your willpower to make this work as
somebody who's and sober a minute and
well versed in you know the recovery
parlament like I'm very familiar with
the limits of willpower like willpower
will Avail you nothing in in a true
addiction context so it makes me think
about our relationship with food through
that lens if willpower is not the
solution it has to be a different
approach altogether which is what you
get into with mindfulness and and and
awareness and the like but maybe explain
why why willpower doesn't work like why
can't we just summon the will to
navigate the discomfort change these
habits and get to the other side of it
it seems like it should it seems like it
should and that's the question we can
ask is and this has been a debate that's
been going on for hundreds if not
thousands of years is this and we don't
need to get into the willpower debate
because you can think of this as free
will debate right if we have free will
we can make decisions and we can choose
Our Fate so by ition we should be able
to use our willpower to change
habits philosophers tend to disagree
that there is even a thing of willpower
it's more they describe it more as an
illusion that's part of the system as do
neuroscientists yes and so from a
neuroscience standpoint I mean depends
on how crazy we want to get here or you
know sciency we want to get here if you
look at the equations for habit change
let's just go there and we can bypass
the Free Will debate for now there's no
variable for willpower in Behavior
change whether it's forming a habit or
changing a habit willpower is not part
of the equation so then what is
willpower like is there a way to
identify like a locus of it in the brain
and what is the the kind of default
disposition that we have or relationship
that we have with willpower where we're
so insistent that that that's the path
that we should be pursuing yeah so the
closest that people have gotten is their
prefrontal cortex and particular the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex or kind
of up up you know like more lateral in
forward in our head that seems to be
involved in cognitive control cognitive
control does not equal 100% willpower
that's but that's kind of how the best
somebody could map you know the
phenology of willpower onto cognitive
control and when you look at that it
seems to be tied to kind of reward how
rewarding a behavior is or isn't and we
can get into that in a minute
that's the best that people have gotten
is well here's the cognitive control
centers of the brain and again these are
networks it's not just single brain
regions if you take that one step
farther where people have tried to find
the locus of of Consciousness even you
know nobody's been able to find that yet
so what exactly is willpower where is it
the best I can suggest I'll give you
some baseless speculation some BS so my
BS answer here is that one thing that is
known uh and if you look at Alzheimer's
for example as an extreme example of
this is that we tend to confabulate we
tell a story about the world that fits
with how we see the world and that's not
limited to people with Alzheimer's
disease that's just where you can see
you know somebody's like making
something up that you're like you know
I'm looking right here and they're like
Mo I swear that's true that's their
brain trying to make sense of the world
in a way where they're struggling with
their neural connections aren't aren't
all quite
there someone suggested that we are
doing that on a consistent basis is just
that our stories line up better and so
we're like oh yeah this must be me doing
things MH there's this famous liit
experiment uh from I think the 1970s
they put um EG electrodes on people's
motor cortex and they had they timed
when they had the urge to tap a tap
their finger on something like something
very simple and they found that the
motor cortex was getting ready to fire a
full half second before they were
consciously aware of it and that's been
replicated it's very elegant experiment
you could say oh there's good evidence
of confabulation that we're
confabulating we're saying oh yeah I
just moved my hand when my my hand was
going to move and I told the story that
was consistent with my hand moving so a
lot of this could be driven by what our
our conditioned experience is going to
do and then we tell the story afterwards
and so that
story includes willpower right that also
brings up the Free Will issue because if
your neurons are firing or something is
happening in your brain before you have
a conscious awareness of a decision that
you're making or a behavior that you're
engaging in are you really consciously
choosing that yeah yeah so I don't want
to go too down deep down that because I
do want to make this practical but uh
worth considering good footnote and go
look up the live experiment well we say
like uh as they say in AA like self-will
you know will Avail you nothing
here every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new nextg Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but on also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is engineered
for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com
well if willpower doesn't work what is
efficacious in the context of weight
loss or reshaping our relationship with
food so you go on this journey to try to
understand setting aside willpower what
is the best way to help people reshape
how they interact with food so that they
can live healthier yeah well the short
answer is use your brain and the longer
answer yeah that's that's I don't know
that's not help help me not pragmatic
enough use your brain come on come on
Rich use your brain yeah will you tell
the joke in the book of like the what is
it that you know you pay $5 and the guy
shouts at you just stop it you know yeah
that is a great Bob newart kid anybody
should watch it it's called stop
it so the way that we can look at this
is what's consistent and what's powerful
in the brain so if we know that the
prefrontal cortex is the youngest and
the weakest part of the brain so it's
the first that goes offline when we're
hungry angry lonely tired right that's
the halt acronym anybody in addiction
treatment knows if you can't rely on
your willpower you got to see well
what's happening when your prefrontal
cortex is going offline well you're
reverting to your older evolutionary
mechanisms what are those they're habits
how do you form habits it's through this
process of reinforcement learning and so
we took this crazy approach and said
well if this is really strong let's
study those equations and see what
that's up to and see if we can actually
leverage that and so we can kind of
subvert the dominant Paradigm by using
it against itself and so the way that
that works is it's actually a pretty
simple equation these two guys R
scorland and Wagner back in the 70s put
it forward and it's still true we still
use these equations today they're really
powerful from mice all the way to humans
and the way that works is that you set
up a reward value of a certain Behavior
right and you you kind of have this
reward hierarchy in your brain about
where that fits relative to other
behaviors cuz we're all you know
relatives like I might like a certain
type of chocolate and you might like a
different type of chocolate right we've
got different relative reward values for
that type of chocolate so we set up that
reward value so that our brain can make
quick decisions so if I'm getting
chocolate a let's say um a dark
chocolate with sea salt and cayenne
pepper something like that you know and
then I compare it to a different
chocolate that's like you know 85%
versus 80 I'm like oo this one's nice
it's got a nice mouth feel to it's
slightly Smoky whatever that's higher in
the reward hierarchy and so I don't have
to eat both of those every time and make
a decision
if I've learned I like B more than a I
see b and a I'm just going to pick B and
so this is this reward hierarchy that's
set up in our brain uh the orbital front
on cortex is like the Hub of that so
that's the main part of the equation is
you've got this learned reward value of
a behavior and then if you look at
changing that like the current reward
value is going to equal the the one
that's set think of that as the habitual
reward Value Plus an error term and
that's it there are only three variables
in the equation the one you know x equal
x - one like that you know at the
previous time point plus an error term
that error term is really interesting uh
let's get pragmatic here right I'm not a
mathematician myself so I like to talk
pragmatics let's say a new um Bakery
opens up in my neighborhood right and so
I have a certain reward value for
chocolate cake in my brain I go in the
bakery their chocolate cake looks pretty
good and so I go try it and if it's like
the best chocolate cake I've ever had I
get what's called a positive prediction
ER as in it's better than expected
dopamine fires and I learn hey eat this
cake and then I go later I anticipate it
you know so I get the URS to go to the
bakery again so I've learned something
like this is good cake if on the other
hand I eat it and it's not very good I
get what's called a negative prediction
eror I'm like eh not very good I've also
learned something dopamine Spritz it
says hey don't go back to this Bakery
both of those require one critical thing
which is awareness you have to pay
attention as you're eating the cake so
if I'm on my phone like on an important
call while I'm eating the cake my wife
says hey how's the bakery I'm I don't
know I haven't paid attention so that
old habitual reward value stays the same
if I don't pay attention does that make
sense yeah sure so taking all of that
and then laying it on top of this
lattice work or framework around
compulsive eating or unhealthy eating
habits like how does that inform how you
then counsel somebody who you know can't
stop eating corn nuts or gummy bears
yeah so I go right to the math and right
to the neuroscience and I say pay
attention and to to expound upon that a
little bit and also I want to pause here
and just give a shout out to the people
that form the stories in my book as you
saw these are wonderful people who made
themselves vulnerable so I could tell
their authentic stories and so people
could see what they struggle with and
how they worked with it so I just want
to give a shout out to this well my
favorite is is her name Jackie yeah the
mindful
teacher who secretly you know has all
these crazy habits around food and feels
ashamed like I think that's a very
relatable thing like the disconnect or
the Polar Opposites of like I teach this
thing and I tell these people to do this
and I'm secretly behaving this way you
know what I mean and how awful that must
feel for her and the trap the like you
know sort of prison that you create for
yourself I think is something that you
know maybe not on such an extreme level
but uh you know I think a lot of people
can kind of relate to like I say I do
this thing and then left in my own
devices I end up doing all these other
things and I feel horrible about myself
and that emotional state U then
motivates me to splurge and indulge even
more because I'm so uncomfortable with
those emotions and it's this cycle that
perpetuates and you know the grooves get
deeper and deeper and deeper until it
feels impossible to break free yeah
absolutely absolutely so shout out to
them Beautiful Stories and the reason I
bring them forward now is that when we
look at this question around like okay
how do we actually leverage this stuff
having people pay attention you know
like when my patients come into my
office I have them like map out these
habit loops and start paying attention
as they're indulging in these
behaviors and that's going straight to
the neuroscience and saying okay the
only variable here that's going to
change anything is awareness right
you've got to pay attention as you do
something and we can even build this in
so we've built this into our right now
app where we can study it and we can see
how quickly Behavior changes when
somebody pays attention because you know
like you're pointing out with Jackie's
story we can tell ourselves to stop
doing things but that's not going to
work right and we can then live a shame
filled life or we can start learning how
our brain works and then you know change
that whole thing so
essentially the solution lies in being
complet present and non-judgmental with
what is happening on some level it's a
bit like the inventory aspect of of 12st
Step where it's like let's just really
from 10,000 ft look at what you're
actually doing and like don't get upset
with yourself like let's just create the
map here's what's going on so we can see
it for what it actually is when it's
happening and the more present and aware
you are with that behavior it ends up
acting like an antidote to the kind of
trigger response that traditionally
occurs when you're not paying attention
or you're not actually thinking about
what you're doing and I guess where I
sort of you know bristle a little bit or
like my bias comes in with this is you
know as somebody who is an addict and an
alcoholic I'm all too familiar with the
just overpowering nature of what a
craving can look like so powerful that I
will literally lie cheat and steal I
will put myself in harm I will put other
people in harm and you become so
inoculated from any kind of outside
messages that would dissuade you from
you know meeting that need that is like
put you into tunnel focus and just blots
out the rest of the world that it makes
it hard for me to hear the counsel of
anyone other than the like-minded souls
who see the world that I do so I'm just
admitting that you know and you treat
people like this and you're familiar
with
but bias it's oh here's guy's not you
know J's not anol or addict he does he
do how just completely derailing this
can be yeah well I've certainly seen it
way too many times as you have and the
the bristling I think is important and
again you certainly know this better
than I do I've only lived it vicariously
through my patients and and the folks in
our program but this all consuming
craving the nice thing here and I think
this is actually pretty aligned with 12
steps for example is that you know don't
try to fight the craving and Jackie
actually talks about this fighting the
craving monster it only makes it
stronger and you resist persist kind of
thing right and this is where I like the
Marcus aelius quote like what what
stands in the way becomes the way
instead of like trying to fight a
craving you know especially when it's
all consuming we can't fight it and so
what can we do instead well in the
aftermath instead of judging ourselves
because that well you tell me but that's
what I see happen most often in the
aftermath is it's another habit Loop of
somebody judging themselves that gets
away from learning and so you said this
earlier I want to just go back and
highlight that it's critical that people
and not saying it's easy because self
judgment's also you big habit that we
can get in but the more we can bring
kindness and acceptance to ourselves and
see oh this is just my brain that's gone
off track as compared to there's
something wrong with me that opens Us in
the aftermath of whatever happened you
know these crazy binge episodes which
are very similar to alcohol binges right
afterwards we can look at it and say
what happened and what really happened
in terms of the negative consequences
here because that rock bottom piece is
what helps us start to wake up and say
there's got to be another way yeah I
think the overlap with 12ep comes in
with with the recognition of these
Behavior patterns and then you know
developing The Reflex to kind of go
share it and hear other people share
their versions of it so you don't feel
alone and that diminishes the shame
piece like you feel like-minded with a
group of people and I mean if there is a
habit that you learn it's that before
you indulge you go and you you share it
and there's something about like
bringing voice to it that dampens the
craving and the urge and I think on top
of that is this idea of not fighting the
craving like you were saying
acknowledging it and understanding that
feelings are just feelings and I think
we're hardwired in our lizard brain or
whatever part of the brain that that you
would you know classify it
scientifically to believe that these
feelings really do want to kill us like
it is life or death and so we give them
much more credulity than they deserve
and if we can just sit with them what
happens every single time 100% of the
time without fail is that they pass they
go away yeah so instead of you know that
resist persist piece right instead of
pushing against them if we open our arms
and accept them right it's the surrender
piece on some level yeah and so if you
don't give them something to push
against that's the acceptance piece then
they just come and they just keep going
because there's nothing to push against
but I going to circle back to something
that you said earlier I'd love to
explore this a little bit more because
I'm I think I'm starting to see a
parallel here that I hadn't seen before
so you said when people come together
and share you know what they're about to
do the craving goes away can we explore
that a little bit more so I say that
because this is really interesting in
our eating program we find that we have
people pay attention as they overeat we
created this craving tool that then as
they do this enough and they gather we
call this Gathering disenchantment data
because they start to see oh overeating
doesn't feel good doesn't feel good
doesn't feel good as they gather those
data they can then call that more easily
they're like oh last time I did that
this happened so when you said when
somebody comes together and shares what
they're about to do well how's their
brain simulating what it's going to be
like when they do it they're recalling
previous memories because the past is
what predicts the future and that's what
our brain is using for this predictive
processing to say hey it was like this
in the past and it's going to be like
this in the future so if you bring it in
front of the Forum where people are
bearing witness so they're keeping you
honest I would guess my hypothesis is is
BR is less likely to be like well it
wasn't so bad because they're going be
like really wasn't so bad and they're
going to start questioning which then
forces that memory to be more accurate
and with an accurate memory if we feel
into what happened
before and we're like oh that wasn't so
good that's where the disenchantment
builds and we see this exact thing
happening with eating the more people
can recall what it was like last time
the easier it is for them to become
disenchanted and not do it it again so
I'm curious what your thoughts are on
that yeah I mean the disenchantment
database I immediately thought of that
because the parallel the more appropo
parallel in in recovery is the context
in which you call your sponsor or you
call somebody and you're like I'm
getting ready to do this thing and I'm
going to do it and instead of the person
on the other line saying don't do that
they're just like okay tell me what it
looks like you know what is that okay
cool like Okay so let's say you do it
then so you take that drink and then
what happens
like well then I'm do this I'm do that
cool okay and then what and then what
and then what and then what and
invariably it leads you down that path
to well I wake up and I'm in Vegas and I
lost my wallet and uh you know my wife
has left and you know you you just play
it out to its conclusion and you are
then very connected to the results of
that kind of behavior so it conjures
that memory and and perhaps
neurochemically creates a certain kind
of GrooVe that makes you more resistant
to indulging in that behavior that time
or the next yeah and that Groove comes
from the remembrance of the embodied
experience and I want to highlight that
because this is not about thinking our
way out of an issue whether it's
overeating or drinking or whatever this
is about feeling our way out and into a
new way of being because that feeling
body is much stronger than the thinking
brain right we've all had that
experience of of picking up a bag of
whatever could be baruka nuts which we
have over here or it could be Gummy
Bears or it could be potato chips that's
my weak spot um and not being able to
just eat one because these foods not
baruka nuts but ultr processed foods are
scientifically engineered with billions
of dollars behind them to create the
precise ratio of salt sugar and fat to
make it almost impossible to resist and
then we feel shame we end up doing it
again we're stuck in this this Loop and
I think we come up with Nar ative
stories like you just said well this was
how whatever but what we're not doing is
really we're not really connecting with
the trigger the emotional state that led
to that behavior and we're also not
cognizant of the difference between
hunger and craving we just say well we
were hungry you know I needed to eat so
let's differentiate hunger from craving
and how we can begin to understand the
difference between those two things when
it comes to making a choice it's a good
point that we should really double down
on and so here they're actually two
different they're described as
homeostatic hunger and honic hunger so
interesting they still use hunger here
because like you're highlighting one is
based on just craving even in the
absence of the need for calories that's
the honic hunger whereas the homeostatic
hunger is as it sounds it's like hey
homeostasis is out of balance I need to
get it back into balance and so that
very adaptive physi ologic mechanism
says Hey eat some food so you can you
can get the calories that you need and
so the homeostatic hunger piece you know
it's this is striking to me because when
I first started working with people with
binge eating
disorder I assumed that they could still
tell the difference like when they were
actually hungry versus when they weren't
and that was actually not true at all I
worked with a group of of women with
binge eaing disorder and I I felt like I
was missing something for the first
several weeks that we were working
together I was like what am I missing
what am I missing and I basically asked
this question like well don't you don't
you eat when you're hungry and they're
like what no I just have a craving and I
eat and that was it so the difference
between homeostatic hunger and honic
hunger was gone they had no distinction
well they probably never reach
homeostatic hunger because the craving
is always satisfied in the honic context
certainly could be the case yeah
absolutely and if you're itch just
starts itching and you immediately
scratch it how are you going to tell
where that itch is coming from right and
so I think you know going back to your
question certainly we can have a craving
when we have homeostatic hunger that's
how we're set up is to say Hey you know
stomach's rumbling go get some food in
modern day more and more where we've
learned to eat not because of hunger but
because of sadness boredom anger
whatever we've learned through these
ironically they're supposed to be these
adaptive mechanisms but they're anti-
adaptive because they're not helpful for
our health where we're like oh I'm
stressed that doesn't feel good go eat
some food oh I'm bored go eat something
you get the gist there and so that gets
ingrained more and more and more to the
point where people aren't even paying
attention to their bodies anymore it's
astonishing how that operates and I've
experienced that myself I mean I got
sober and spent the next 10 years
blindly unaware of how I had transferred
all of that attic energy into my food
choices and the relationship between
what I was eating and the emotional
state that I was in was completely
Beyond me until I kind of you know
reached a nere with it and looked at it
for the very first time and I had all
these tools and I still wasn't seeing it
and I was like what do you mean I'm an
emotional eater you know but then when
you look at it you're like well oh my
God like when you do that inventory
you're like holy [__] yeah it's
incredible and it's empowering because
you realize like oh when I feel like
this or when this is happening or I just
you know mindlessly reach for this thing
it is the self that makes those
uncomfortable emotions go away and so
when you're counseling people around
breaking up with those habits you're
asking them to divorce themselves from
what is perhaps their best friend yeah
even if they're not aware of it yeah
absolutely it's so powerful yeah I mean
they're best friends for a reason right
they provide a lot of comfort for us dis
angling this knot and and getting to the
root of how you can drive these better
habits getting back to the mindfulness
piece and the awareness piece you have
this 21 Day program my first question is
why 21 days we'll get to that okay but
it really is set up it's a it's sort of
a three tiered approach the first two
tiers are really focused on this
inventory process of connecting the
person with who they are and undertaking
all of these tasks to create that
connect and that level of awareness and
get rid of all the guilt and the shame
and the stories that go with all of this
so first answer the 21 day question and
then let's get into you know what the
program actually is yeah so I was trying
to have a little levity and fun here and
so the 21-day program is honestly it's a
tongue and cheek nod to an internet
myth which is if you look on the
internet and H ask how long does it take
to form a new habit you're going to find
the the answer is 21 you know it's not
the the universal number of 42 but it's
close enough right it's 21 where did
that come from plastic surgeon in the
1960s wrote a book about how long it
took his patients to get used to their
new nose jobs that's the origin of that
that's it and then people like oh 21
days sounds pretty good and then you
just get something you know trending at
the top on the internet as long as
people just keep referencing it it's
going to stay at the top I know this is
hard to hear but sometimes things on the
internet aren't
true oh no what am I going to do Jud 21
days feel short to me I I just know in
my own case like trying to sh shift or
change any kind of behavior takes a lot
longer yeah and people are in a rush and
the temporal nature of that plays into
the idea of why dtes don't work also
like having this Finishing Line yeah so
the reality here is it isn't about like
something's going to change in 21 days I
read about this in the book one of our
studies we we found that in 10 to 15
times of somebody using our craving tool
that reward value in their brain drops
below zero but that doesn't line up with
days somebody could be doing this you
know and paying attention 10 to 15 times
like within a couple of days the 21 days
is this tongue and cheek you know nod to
that but it's really about here's a way
to break it down into 21 steps or 21
things that you can bring together it's
really about if somebody's going to
change Behavior quickly most people are
going to take several months to really
get the gist of it and then it's going
to take a little bit longer to really
nail it and be like wow this is I'm a
lifer with this because once we really
in see how good it feels to like stop
overindulging into eat healthy food it's
it's really hard to go back so it's I
think of it more as is you know here are
21 things that you can bring together as
compared to you're going to nail it in
21 days right the first prong here is
what you call mapping your habit Loops
so what does that mean
it's as simple as taking those three
elements that we talked about the
trigger the behavior and the reward of
the result and just being able to
identify them in Vivo like as we go
through in our daily life let's use
stress eating oh here I'm walking into
the refrigerator I'm not hungry but I'm
stressed out okay there's the there's
the behavior I'm about to stress eat can
we map back and see what triggered it oh
stress for example and then can we map
it forward and get that third element of
like what's the result of of the stress
eating so we can map The Habit Loop out
before we do it we can map it out when
we do it we can map it out afterwards
like somebody wants to journal at the
end of their day they can look back on
their day and see how many times they
stress eight and just map out that Loop
so it's not even about arresting the
behavior it's more about paying
attention and the noticing of it and and
taking the kind of self- judgment and
shame out of it and allowing some space
for for self-compassion and just being
The Observer of of your own life yeah
and I think of it as like here's a great
opportunity to learn who doesn't want to
learn how their mind works right and so
this is a simple model that can be
brought Way Beyond food food's a great
way to start mapping this out because we
have so many food habits but then we can
start to see oh this applies to my
social media habit oh this applies to me
checking email when I've got a project
that's due you know last time I checked
the average email in the US goes unread
for only three minutes wow cuz people
you know they're constantly checking
their email and they also have their
alerts on and they get distracted by it
so the mapping process is simple and
I'll make it even simpler the trigger
doesn't matter and let that sit for a
minute because a lot of people are like
what the Trigg you know if I could just
avoid my triggers one of my patients
told me he's like people places and
things if I can Avid those then I won't
drink which of course duh you know if
you V the liquor store in the bar you're
less likely to drink the problem is that
we have to eat you don't have to drink
but you have to eat so here one it's
really hard to avoid triggers but more
important than that the triggers aren't
what reinforce the process they aren't
what keep it going they just set the
thing in motion so the triggers are the
least important part of the equation so
if somebody's going to start mapping
their habit Loop out find the behavior
right they can do it before during or
after and then start exploring what the
result is and that's where it gets
really important and that shifts into
the second step that's so interesting I
I can't help but think about my own
experiences with food and trying to
manage my habits and we were sharing
before the podcast started that I've
been on a little bit of a journey
recently the last year and a half two
years I've been sedentary more than I
have been historically since I turned 40
as a result of a chronic lower back
issue which I'm in the process of
resolving but that has sidelined me more
than I care to admit and I haven't been
able to run and move my body in the way
that I like to and that allow ows me to
feel like who I am but with that kind of
reduction in physical output I took with
me my eating habits that fueled all of
those endurance challenges and although
I eat quite clean and probably cleaner
than most people I am prone to large
portion sizes and and it it's been very
challenging to reduce those because you
say you know don't pay attention to the
trigger then there's the behavior but
once you take that first bite find
myself powerless to like slow it down
and just be mindful and allow that 20
minute window where your body kind of
catches up to what you're doing and
sends those signals that that you've had
enough and that's been difficult and
although I would say I probably bring a
level of mindfulness and awareness to
what I'm doing I certainly have room for
improvement there but what has worked
for me to some extent and perhaps this
is willpower adjacent is creating binary
rules and maybe that's because of my
experience in 12ep it's like you're
either sober or you're not you're either
drinking or you're not drinking it's an
onoff switch there's no gray area and I
just say okay I'm going to take this
food like off the table and there's no
further decisions to be made like this
is just not something I'm going to have
and I'm pretty good with sticking with
that and it doesn't feel like a
willpower thing it's like once I've made
that decision I'm pretty good about
adhering to that but portion is a gray
Zone you know it's like it's not like
there's no there's no onoff switch for
that you know what I mean so this is
like and I've made great progress I'm
doing good and I feel better than I did
six months ago um but I'm wondering like
this I this isn't really a question this
is more like me using you as my
psychiatrist right now good free
session so this is interesting because
so just getting at that why is the
binary feel easier from an energy
standpoint
well willpower is about making a
decision I'm not going to do this I'm
not going to do this whereas if you've
made a decision that you are not X like
I don't eat sugar I don't drink alcohol
I don't do this you're not making a
decision anymore you know you're kind of
imagining yourself as not that so
there's no psychic drain or decision
fatigue involved yeah you know some
people they're like well I've tried that
and doesn't work you know the switch
comes back on but for a lot of people it
can be very helpful just that that
binary piece and you can do that with
certain aspects of food right that's
what I see the most is people are like I
just stop eating sugar and it's easier
or processed sugar so that's easier for
them but you've got to eat right and so
if you eat let's use the r roll
experience here you eat super clean food
right you're probably not eating much of
any processed sugar but you you've got
this food in front of you and your habit
is like well got to get this number of
calories in because I just burnt this
number of calories because I went for a
20 mile run so here it's like well I
can't just tell myself to stop doing it
because as the we talk talked about the
willpower may not work but this is where
we can bring the power of awareness in
and if we're in the habit of just
shoveling it down that's the first thing
we've got to pay attention to is hey if
I'm just shoveling it down what am I
getting from this right so that helps us
become disenchanted with the shoveling
so then we say okay well I'm going to
pay attention as I eat and that's where
we can start exploring what I call the
pleasure Plateau because our wise body
is going to tell us when we've had
enough and that's be a different Plateau
if you've gone for a 20 mile run versus
if you haven't mhm does that make sense
no it does it does it does I'm just
imagining
myself sitting in front of a plate of
food that's probably larger than what I
need and what my mind is doing is saying
yeah but that's not the satisfying super
clear here's what you do kind of answer
you know because the responsibility
still sits with you to conjure the
awareness and do that kind of work which
is not easy and kind of like ephemeral I
agree and we can disentangle a couple of
things to make it easier so one just
knowing that our brains don't like
ambiguity they prefer quantitative clear
results you know this is why the the
likes on social media have been so
addictive because we know exactly where
we stand versus like actually throwing
caution into the wind and like having a
conversation with somebody and looking
at their body language and be like what
what is this this going well are we
doing exactly so if we can learn to
tolerate that ambiguity and even lean
into it and get curious this is where
curiosity becomes the superpower we can
learn not to fear ambiguity so that's
one thing if we can disentangle and pull
out the ambiguity piece then we can get
to the heart of it and it gets easier
and that is that we if as we start
paying attention right we can bring the
Curiosity in so first let me back up and
say we start by seeing what happens when
we don't do it so that brings in that
motivation that's like the Rock Bottom
it's like oh when I don't pay attention
I over eat and I feel crappy okay that
crappiness motivates me to want to
change now change can feel hard or it
cannot feel hard so how do we get it to
not feel hard this is where we bring in
curiosity as a superpower when you're
curious about something how hard is it
to pay attention to it no it's natural
okay so we could say okay great let's
leverage that Curiosity because it in
itself is going to make this not feel as
hard as what I might have been trying in
but how do you conjure that Curiosity
curiosity is not something you can
compel another and I don't know how you
can possibly conjure it in yourself
especially if your habit loops and your
patterns around self-judgment
self-criticism shame guilt or whatever
you experience when you make that wrong
choice being being asked to supplant
that with C it's okay just put that
aside and be curious how do you actually
do that yeah I think of it this is you
got to work with what's in front of you
first so if somebody's stuck in a
self-judgment habit Loop they can use
these same tools to work with that first
but if they're stuck in self judgment
they can't bring curiosity to eating
they've got to work with the self
judgment first so here asking themselves
what am I getting from beating myself up
and feeling into that again feeling body
much stronger than thinking brain so
when they feel self judgment doesn't
feel good and they just start exploring
dipping their toe in the water of
kindness and like which one feels better
no brainer kindness feels better and so
we can start to lean into kindness as a
way to help us step out of these
self-judgment habit lives and we have to
do that enough so that we can actually
start paying attention to the food in
the first place right so there's all
these blockers but we can't ignore them
we have to start with the blockers and
get ourselves unblocked you know and
self judgment is the big one I'm sure
you've had many patients who come to you
you've explained just this to them and
they say but trying to feel kindness for
myself feels indulgent and it feels
unearned or undeserved because I'm
fundamentally bad and broken don't you
know that Jud or I wouldn't be sitting
here with you right so I don't know how
to be kind to myself and when I try to
do that it feels like a shoe that
doesn't fit yeah that's a good point I'm
glad you bring this forward because I
see this a lot so there are two places I
start outside of self-kindness one is
think of a time when somebody's been
kind to you and almost everybody can
think of one you know at some point in
in the past hopefully less distant than
more distant and I have them feel into
that what does kindness itself feel like
right so they can just feel into the
experience of kindness oh it feels
pretty good now they're already a little
closer to the self-kindness then I ask
them what's it feel like when you're
kind when you're genuinely kind to
somebody else and fortunately most
people are like oh yeah I can think of a
time and it feels good and hopefully it
was like just earlier today you know
where they're practicing kindness so we
know that kindness is there and then
they can actually bring curiosity in and
be like hey what's it what's it like
when you've actually cared for yourself
so there's a difference between
self-kindness and
self-indulgence and so we can do a
little bit of Education around that
where it's like self-indulgence is like
oh yeah I deserve the ice cream or
whatever and so they indulge versus I
actually needed the calories and so we
can break out of the loops of like the
self-indulgence which is that story We
Tell ourselves versus oh I'm meeting my
need when we meet our needs it actually
feels pretty good and there's an act of
self-kindness that is pretty simple
relatively straightforward and it can
feel Rusty at first until we do it but
then it's like oh we can reflect back on
it well how many times did I meet my
needs today okay there's an act of
self-kindness how does that feel so we
can actually back our way in into it by
recognizing times when we've actually
done this or at least other people have
done it to us or we've done it to others
so we can start Awakening that light of
kindness we're brought to you today by
Roa glasses are not something you
normally think about as a piece of
performance gear which when you think
about it is kind of insane because you
can't perform at your best if you can't
see well the Geniuses at Roa basically
rebuilt eyewear from the ground up no
matter how active you are or how much
you sweat these things never slip or
fall off your face they're super durable
they look awesome and they've got tons
of super classy modern styles to choose
from I've been rocking Ras for about
four years at this point I love them I'm
a big fan of the Hamilton style in gloss
black that's this Frame right here as
well as clear or I guess they call them
vintage on the website and uh if you
want to try them out for yourself you
can do that right now and unlock 20% off
your order with the code Rich Roll at
roka.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
[Music]
show distinguishing
between Cravings hedonic hunger and true
hunger um feels analogous to this idea
of trying to understand the difference
between wants and needs yeah they're
fine lines for a lot of people and
fundamental to this whole idea of
mapping your habit Loops or your whole
program entirely involves a greater
level of connection with self yeah but I
think most
people even if they struggle with their
weight or their food choices they're
living their lives so detached from
their bodies and the choices they're
making around what they put in their
mouth that this is a brand new idea to
them like they just you get up you eat
what you eat and you're just kind of
reacting to the world and the stress and
just trying to get through the day and
you go to the drive-thru and you hit the
7-Eleven and on the way home back to the
you just you're just doing what you do
and because these foods are so unhealthy
and because they hit all of those
hormonal hot spots that light you up
that person might not even know what it
would feel like to actually feel good in
their body or feel connected to who they
are so to get them to that place that's
a long road when you're like well you
just have to really connect with
yourself yeah yeah like this is not
going to happen quickly for most people
who have been eating most of their lives
in a certain way yeah and I know this
from my own personal experience I'm not
standing on any kind of high horse here
yeah well you know reminds me of that
quote of you know Journey Of A Thousand
Miles begins with the first step and so
here even with so I totally agree with
all of that and I would say it's worth
the journey and if somebody can take a
single step forward Ward and see the
benefit of that single step which could
be simply they're at the 7-Eleven
they've got the 32 o
Slurpee and they start paying attention
as they're drinking it I don't know how
anybody can down one of those as quickly
as a lot of people do I know I know so
if they start paying attention and they
just start asking well how is this sip
relative to the last Sip and they just
get curious like oh is this still is
tasty they can actually start leveraging
that pleasure Plateau piece where are
starting to see oh this isn't you know
I'm actually starting to get full and
even that helps them see oh what's it
feel like not to like slurp it to the
bottom versus like stop when I'm full
and you know then go back and finish it
later that's different than like just
hammering it now and then feeling crappy
and then not making that Association
that like when I hammer this 32 oz drink
I feel pretty crappy to me it feels like
the easier choice is to not even take
the first slurp than to try to drink a
little bit of it and then have the
mindful awareness to put it aside
because once I've indulged and begun
that process and the train is pulled out
of the station my disposition is I have
to see it all the way through to its
Bitter End you know what I mean that's
why these binary choices feel easier for
me like I just don't if I don't taste it
then I'm not setting in motion all of
whatever is going on in my brain that is
compelling me to like keep eating or
keep drinking this thing yeah absolutely
as you highlight earlier so there are
certain like we don't have to buy a
slurpie but if somebody is so compelled
to buy a Slurpee or they have to you
know they've got to eat dinner and
they're habitually overeating they've
got to work with what's in front of them
you have this great James Joyce quote
that I'm going to read it's basically
about how people often live at a
distance from their bodies treating them
as mere carriers for their brains the
challenge is that this disconnect makes
it difficult to listen to and learn from
from the body signals it's so true yeah
so James Joyce wrote this famous line in
his short story what was it a a painful
case where he says Mr Duffy lived a
short distance from his body yeah you
know I think we all do to some extent
yeah it reminded me of bertran Russell's
five different types of eaters do you do
you know about this no tell me oh this
is great I wrote it down because I was
like oh yeah this is like he has a whole
thing about mindful eating no his whole
thing is like how you need to eat slow
and friends and he's written extensively
about this I don't know it's you can
find it of different places but this is
probably um but he no he he identified
that there are five ways that people eat
this is from the conquest of Happiness
there's the boore and that's the person
who's never known hunger and basically
just eats whatever they want and has
never connected with true hunger right
they're just satisfying their Cravings
there's the invalid who just eats
joylessly like they're just eating to
satisfy their nutritional needs uh The
Epicure who's the snob and like
nothing's good enough no matter what
fantastic meal they have before them
it's done wrong and this isn't right
there's the gormandizer
gormandizer that's the rapacious eater I
would put myself in that category and
then finally the fifth is the person
with the sound appetite and that is the
mindful eater who has a balanced
approach to what they're eating and how
they're eating but he has a lot to say
about the benefits of like slowing down
and paying attention to the food that
you're eating yeah well it's interesting
and I'll have to look that it more but I
love those five types I was trying to
trace the history of like this mindful
eating piece and of a friend biku Alo is
German born monk who's got this
photographic memory basically and I was
talking to him about this and he's like
oh there's actually a suta there's a
poly Canon writing about
about overeating this king panati who
used to overeat and he actually went to
the Buddha like hey basically I'm I'm
I've got clinical obesity I got problems
here can you help me and the Buddha said
you know basically pay attention as you
eat and you'll stop eating when you're
full and you'll lose weight of course
he's a king so he pays somebody to like
every time he's got a meal he's like hey
remember King pay attention as you eat
so not all Tak responsibility for paying
attention he pays somebody to pay
attention for yeah yeah well or to
remind him at least because he still had
to pay attention the other guy couldn't
say hey it you know looks like you've
had enough he had to just remind the
king and the King did well um but I
think it's that's interesting that you
can find these stories all the way back
2 200 years where the Buddha is actually
talking about this very simple concept
of paying attention as you eat and
that's all you
need yeah the human brain's like no it
can't be that easy like take me behind
the Velvet Rope like I need the VIP
program here um but there is something
to the idea of of slowing down
physiologically because of this 20
minute window where it takes the body
that much time before the signals to
your brain that say you had enough or
you're full right yeah can you talk a
little bit about that because that's a
very practical like if you slow down
this is what you will experience yeah
the good news is we don't have to slid
in it for an hour right 20 minutes is
reasonable for you unless you're just
eating a small snack the pragmatic piece
of this is if you shovel down your
entire dinner in 5 minutes it's going to
be really hard to tell if you've
overeaten until until you hit that 20
minute Mark and you're like oh that
didn't work so well and so it's that's
all there is to it really it's I
recognize how this is not always
pragmatic especially for people who are
working multiple jobs who may be a
single parent things like that and
they're like I'm just lucky that I can
eat a meal because often they go without
eating so I just want to name that but
as much as we can if we can at least
give ourselves 20 minutes as we eat
that'll give our body time to get that
signal in there that gets up to our
brain that says hey you're done or hey
maybe a little bit more MH and perhaps
that might help solve that equation or
Square the equation between honic hunger
and what's the other word homeostatic
hunger right like oh this is satiety
versus just a craving you know like I'm
done and I can like and and I think
there's something to the muscle memory
like if you actually do that then you
can check a box and you have a win right
and once you have a win you're on your
way towards building a little bit of
momentum and momentum has a very
powerful spiritual Force to it you know
once you have a little bit of momentum
it's so much easier to extend that mhm
and that comes from reward right if it
feels good good we're going to keep
doing it you're adding that energy in to
keep that momentum going so for example
if we notice oh it actually feels better
to spend 20 minutes eating where I can
actually dial it in as compared to
overeating or undereating there's a win
because it feels good and that builds
the momentum through that reward-based
learning process oh it feels good to do
this what do you say to the person who
time crunched and just says listen you
know like I'm just trying to I'm working
two jobs the only way I can even feed
myself is through the drive-thru or the
quick meal on the whatever this feels
like a very privileged thing I'm I'm
supposed to take my time and prepare my
meals and do all of this like how do you
address that yeah so this is you know we
start where we're at and so if somebody
you know let's say they live in a food
desert they're you know working three
jobs trying to raise their kids by
themselves whatever and the the only
thing they can do is go through the
drive-thru and say great let's start
there and if they only have 5 minutes to
scarf down their food scarf down the
food but at some point they can take 20
seconds and check in with their body and
so whether it's 20 minutes later whether
30 minutes later an hour later they can
check in and be like how did that go
just in terms of did I overeat did I
under eat that's a place to
start then down the road which can be
harder and you know take more resources
is like okay let me compare this to
eating you know maybe it's a prepared
meal but it's not the drive through from
fast food you know you can get healthier
food that's prepared quickly that's not
you know a bunch of ultra processed food
versus Ultra process you can compare
those it still take about the same time
to eat cost about the same the second
pillar in this 21-day program is is
about changing the reward value of
eating behaviors we've already talked
about some of this the first pillar
really being about this inventory and
self-connection and the second piece
really being about cultivating the
awareness and the tension to override
that Willpower Instinct and bring
mindfulness into into your eating
practices we talked about the
disenchantment database and kind of
playing it through you mentioned
pleasure plateaus but you have a couple
other interesting things here the body
scan I want to hear about that and also
this rain technique oh yeah okay so the
body scan is really there to help
reconnect the body and the mind so if Mr
Duffy or any of us live a short distance
from our bodies we got to get back into
our bodies and the body scan you know
this was popularized by this guy Asen
goena um famous for his vasin Retreats
you these Ultra Hardcore 10day silent
meditation Retreats where where people
are spending basically 10 days we call
it the body sweep where they're they're
basically just focusing on different
parts of their bodies they're scanning
or sweeping through their body so they
can start to notice the different
physical Sensations that are there in
any one moment there's nothing you know
radical or complex about it it's really
about simply getting you know you get to
practice curiosity getting curious about
what your body feels like as you scan up
from your toes to your head or from your
head down to your toes and then also
practicing the acceptance so it's like
okay that's Pleasant that's unpleasant
it's there you know noticing our
reaction like whether we skip over it
push against it resist it judge it so
that we can start to become aware of
what our habitual reactions are as we
start
reconnecting with our bodies so how
would that be practically applied in the
context of someone who's like okay I'm
in January I'm trying to really figure
this food thing out is this like a five
minute thing that somebody could do when
they wake up is this something that
somebody would do after they've
overindulged so I think of this as kind
of like a baseline training practice you
know this is like your daily endurance
run right and so this is more of a do it
when you wake up in the morning do it
before you go to sleep at night you know
start with doing it when you can do it
so I like to do it as you go to sleep at
night cuz a lot of people find it
helpful to get get to sleep this way and
they can't say I don't have time to do
it because they got to get to sleep
anyway and even if they start scanning
they fall asleep great they've they've
done a little bit of it so they can do
it in the morning they can do it at
night they can do it when they've got 15
minutes between meetings or something
like that they can do it if they're
riding on a bus and you know going from
one place to another U because all
they're doing is really just focusing on
these different physical Sensations so
it's a very pragmatic tool and practice
to just help reconnect with the body
yeah it's a
mindfulness strategy right it's a very
specific way of channeling a mindful
approach to how you feel absolutely what
is the difference between mindfulness
and a strict meditation practice in the
context of bringing awareness to eating
habits that's a good question I think of
meditation as the this smaller Circle
within a larger Circle Vin diagram of
mindfulness so meditation you you
typically do a meditation practice to
isolate yourself from you know variables
that get in the way of you paying
attention and so here you know you can
sit on a cushion you can do walking
meditation you know there are different
forms of meditation that somebody can do
formally where they're doing a practice
but the meditation itself is doing the
same thing that this larger circle of
mindfulness is doing as well which is
training ourselves to be paying
attention to our our embodied experience
and well basically to all of our
experience both internally and
externally and for somebody who's brand
new to the idea of a practical
mindfulness practice where does one
begin or what is a simple practice other
than the body scan that somebody could
pursue that would initiate them into
this yeah there are a lot of different
meditation practices that people can
practice I like one called called noting
practice and I read about it in the book
a little bit this was popularized by a a
Burmese monk named mahasi Sao and I like
this because you can do this anytime you
don't have to be sitting you can be
walking you can be driving even where
you're it may help you pay attention
even more as you're driving instead of
mindlessly driving where we're basically
just noting whatever is most predominant
in our experience and in the moment so
for example you we're sitting here
talking to each other looking at each
other I might note that I'm seeing and I
might note that I'm hearing if you're
talking I might note feeling as I'm
feeling physical Sensations in my body
and so just about one per second I might
note you know feeling I'm just doing
this in real time seeing hearing hearing
feeling thinking right and so that
noting practice helps us stay present
and notice what's happening in our
experience it's it's pretty simple we're
so insistent on living in the past and
in the future it's it's very hard yeah
it is you know in 12 step it's all about
practicing these principles in all your
Affairs in other words there's
abstinence and then there is emotional
sobriety and then there is bringing
these tools into all of our interactions
our behaviors and how our minds work and
in a similar way this is
about Conjuring a presence like a a
sense of being present with oneself in
the world into the context of eating but
really to your point about like you have
to change your relationship with
yourself how you really interact with
the world around you in all its colors
absolutely it's a big ask but it's sort
of like the eating thing is the Trojan
Horse you know yeah yeah and the way I
think about this is well it certainly is
a big ask but would we rather know this
now or in 10 years mhm I'd rather know
it now because if it can help me get on
the path of reducing suffering now both
for myself and others I want to know it
now sure tell me about the rain
technique so rain is is an acronym for
recognize allow accept investigate and
note so we just talked about the noting
practice and the r just helps us kind of
wake up to what's happening so we
recognize what's happening we recognize
we're in a habit Loop we recognize that
we're an autopilot whatever so that
part's pretty straightforward if you
don't recognize it you're stuck you
can't work with it the a we touched on
this a little bit before is that that
acceptance that allowance if we can't
accept our experience we can't see it
for what it is and so it's really
important to practice not resisting our
experience and if we resist it great we
can use that as practice like oh here's
what resistance feels like what do I get
from this right okay it's not helping me
so we can become disenchanted with
resistance itself but the allowance the
acceptance is really to help us be able
to come close and be honest with
ourselves with our experience right you
can see the importance of that Honesty
that radical honesty so we try to just
see how much we can open to our
experience that's what the allow accept
is is for and it's kind of this reminder
to like okay here it is let me just see
if I can open to it the ey is my
favorite part the investigate and I
think of this is like this is where we
bring in the superpower of curiosity and
we get curious instead of going oh no
here's this craving for whatever we go
oh here's a craving and that opens us
that also helps with the allowance the
acceptance and it helps us start to be
with whatever experience there is let's
say a craving instead of resisting it
like oh oh what is this and then we can
note there's that last part of the N oh
and we note what our experience is like
oh this craving feels like tightness
tension burning heat rising you know
like oh this tightness oh now it's
lessening now it's this now it's this
and so the noting brings in what's
described as thiss observer effect or in
Psychology they call it the Hawthorn
effect where the idea is that if You
observe something you're going to affect
the outcome um physicists talk about to
measure the mass of an electron they had
to measure its momentum and they had to
hit it with photons and they realized
they had to take that into account when
they were measuring the mass because
hitting it with photons was affecting
the measurement this observer effect is
really powerful in Psychology because by
observing our thoughts emotions and Body
Sensations we're actually changing our
relationship to them we're not as
identified with them so the noting is
really helpful with that
non-identification in fact This Acronym
was first developed by meditation
teacher Michelle McDonald and the N
actually stood for non-identification
tarach has really taking this steps
forward where it's like oh in the
western world it's really hard to
understand this concept of
nonidentification I think her current
iteration is like nurture like nurture
ourselves meet our needs yeah but for me
it's how do we not identify exper with
experiences through noting practice and
they happen to both start with n so is
perfect yeah super interesting you had
mentioned earlier that a lot of this
work is about not overly focusing on the
trigger and looking Instead at the
behavior and helping to modify the
behavior by better understanding the
results but I can't help but think when
we're talking about the trigger when you
were discussing the disenchantment
database and I was talking about like
playing it through like okay casting
into the future here's what's going to
happen but similarly I found a practice
to be very effective to cast that gaze
in the other direction like if
I'm really aware that this trigger
results in this type of behavior then
how can I reverse engineer to avoid
putting myself in that triggered
position like because as an alcoholic
like once I'm there like all bets are
off so as they say like the relapse
starts you know way ahead of whatever
you know triggered you to pick up that
drink and developing awareness similar
awareness around all the things that led
to that moment so that you can avoid
putting yourself in those precarious
positions or have strategies around you
know how you might act or behave when
the first little tickle like a week
before when something happened how is
that related to the moment where you
pick up and I'm wondering whether you've
thought about this in the context of
eating or if this has some kind of
applicable strategy here yeah I think
that the parallel is is absolutely there
so whether it's eating or drinking
alcohol something happened a week ago
and it tends to be some disturbance in
the
force it's not like all is good because
all is good we're not going to have that
tickle there's not going to be anything
itching so we if we look a week in ahead
we can can start to see oh generally
there's some need that's not being met
and that need gets filled by a want you
know we feed the wants instead of
meeting the needs and so we can start to
look as you know we can keep an eye out
for are my needs being met because
that's one of the big things that starts
the whole Cascade you gets that snowball
rolling and to the point where it's way
too big we get clobbered by it when it
comes to today MH so the more we can be
aware of those things and then
constantly be on the lookout
not like with over vigilance but just
being really curious like oh asking
ourselves hey am I meeting my needs
today am I doing that if that snowball
starts rolling we can meet it there
before it gets too big and we like oh
wow here's this this emotional need
that's not being met and I tend to cope
with it in an unhealthy way doing this
we can reflect on it then well let's
play the T forward what happens when I
indulge in that and you know we can see
how that that helps us become
disenchanted and then we can start
asking oh well then what do I need right
now how can I meet that need yeah I
think that's really important and
Powerful whether it's a domino effect or
a snowball that's like building in
strength you don't want to have to try
to divert the the snowball when it's
gigantic you know at the Inception of
the behavior moment you want to deal
with it when it's small you can divert
that behavior much more easily but that
requires it's an extra step of awareness
right which is is the accumulation of
these behaviors that lead you to the
point where you can bring that awareness
into your daily life and register in
experience for what it is even though
it's only very tangentially related to
the later behavior that you know you're
going to indulge in if you don't do
something now 10 days ahead you know
what I mean I mean that's a black belt
jiujitsu move but I think that's the
aspiration right well and who doesn't
want to be a black belt of course this
this third pillar of this program is is
really about the behavior change aspect
of this you call it finding more
rewarding behaviors and it talks more
about curiosity and the disenchantment
database is is replaced with the
enchantment database so it's really
about connecting with the impact of
healthy behaviors so talk a little bit
about the philosophy behind this pillar
well this leverages the same very strong
brain Network that we talk about with
the disenchantment and so you know if
our brain has this reward hierarchy and
it starts to see that oh overeating for
example doesn't feel that great it's
going to then start asking well if B
isn't as good as I thought what's better
give me an a aame here and so here we
can start asking ourselves s questions
like well what feels better than
overeating well the simplest one is not
overeating and so even if we start
paying attention and we notice oh it
feels good not to over eat we've already
found that behavior that feels better
and is more rewarding I call this
finding the bbos the bigger better
offers right so not overeating is a
bigger better offer than overeating and
again as I mentioned earlier doesn't
take that long to to find that pleasure
plateau and like oh this feels good and
going off the cliff of overindulgence
doesn't feel good so we can start to
find it in simply like backing off of
the old behaviors and we can start
finding it in the development of new
behaviors that are more aligned with
flourishing for example so we talked
about self judgment what does self
judgment feel like we can compare that
to self-kindness which one feels better
self-kindness so bigger better offer
right and so we're going to lean toward
because it it's a natural gravitational
pull toward the self-kindness when we
can see very very clearly how good it
feels those are just a couple of
examples another little wrinkle here
that feels like it's worth explor
exporing is parsing negative emotions
that we should pay attention to and
negative emotions that we shouldn't you
mentioned what it feels like to
overindulge that doesn't feel good
physically but also there's the guilt
everything that comes along with that
but there's also a different kind of
negative
emotion that maybe we do need to develop
some appreciation for which is the
discomfort that greets us with any
Behavior change and our resistance to
that or our fear around that keeps us
stuck in patterns that don't serve us so
in the context of how we're relating to
our emotions and our feelings how can
you help somebody embrace the necessary
discomfort that will always visit us
when we try to do something on our own
behalf that's different from what we're
used to well this starts with knowledge
being power and what I mean by that is
just knowing that change is scary makes
it less scary just knowing that so I'm
gonna say that again change is scary and
so if we can know and anticipate that
any change might be scary it's like
shining that light into that dark cave
oh it's not as dark it's not as scary as
I thought because we've now reduced that
uncertainty we're like oh I'm expecting
that it's going to feel uncomfortable
the good news there is that we can
actually lean into that discomfort by
using curiosity and you're like oh well
I know that my brain doesn't like change
what does it feel like to resist change
and we get curious and be like oh well
what's it feel like to explore something
new most of us especially if we can
think back to the last time that we were
really curious about something we're
exploring something it's not so scary if
we're going in with that Adventure
mindset if we're going in with like oh
this is going to suck well it's more
likely to suck sure I guess you could
map that on to the enchantment database
like this type of discomfort is coupled
with feelings of self-esteem so I can
create that Association and have a
different lens on how I interpret that
discomfort and not correlate it with
these other kinds of discomfort
discomforts that I should be avoiding
absolutely yeah um how does this work
with trauma you know we've been talking
about emotional
eaing understanding that we make
mindless choices around food when we're
triggered by various emotional states
that are uncomfortable
trauma is sort of an accelerated version
of that something happened to us when
we're young we created a defense
mechanism or a survival strategy that
relates to how we interact with food so
talk a little bit about that because
that seems to be a more acute situation
that might need a different
approach yes and I'm glad you bring this
forward because I've seen so many people
come to me they're very un they weight
because of some traumatic history I'm
thinking about you know a lot of women
um who've had you know sexual trauma
have gained weight as a protective
mechanism so that they were not seen as
attractive and so it was a literal way
to escape you know these types of sexual
aggressions so it can be a very
pragmatic approach that somebody's doing
unconsciously where they're gaining a
bunch of weight that's just one example
but there's also the emotional eating
when you know there's there's all trauma
and we want to use food as a way to numb
ourselves I've had number of patients
talk about it literally in those terms I
I eat to numb myself so we can look at
whatever the mechanism is that that
mechanism that we've developed as a way
to literally help us survive we can then
start asking ourselves well we can first
honor our previous self because often we
blame ourselves oh I should have been
stronger could have done something
different you know anybody that's been
in a in a traumatic situation my heart
goes out to them like that sucked it
shouldn't have happened to them and it's
not their fault that's the first place
that I start because if somebody is
feeling like it's their fault it's going
to be really hard to move forward so I
just want to say that again it's it's
not their fault and then with that we
can bring some kindness in and help them
just honor their previous self and say
look you did the best that you could
right and so I've had patients that
develop worry habit Loops like this guy
that was abused as a kid and his only he
was a kid the only thing he could do was
start worrying because that's the only
thing he had control over he comes to me
in his 60s trying to break this anxiety
habit and we talk through this as you
know it's like well you had some shoes
that fit and they became your go-to
shoes you know like you always wore
these because this is this is the only
pair of shoes you had well now check to
see if those shoes
fit they may not fit you anymore you
might have outgrown those shoes and so
these have become these protective
mechanisms that might paradoxically be
harming us now so the worrying isn't
helping him the overeating or having you
know an unhealthy weight isn't helping
somebody and so here we can honor our
past self and we can lean into the
present and say okay look this was my
brain trying to protect me how can I
help my brain how can we work together
now to see what shoes fit now and that
opens the space for change yeah it's a
very compassionate approach and I think
whether trauma or some less acute
scenario that led to a certain habit we
develop these habits for a reason
they're all adaptive strategies that
that we relied upon because they worked
or they did something for us at some
period of time and now they're not
working for us but our brains don't know
that our bodies don't know that they're
just operating on autopilot assuming
that this is in your best interest and
you have to be in communication with
that and be like it's okay I get it
thank you mhm I appreciate you but we're
good now right yeah it reminds me of uh
Richard schwarz's work with internal
family systems who I know is
controversial in the Psychiatry world
but you know he talks a lot about about
like kind of honoring those impulses
that we have and understanding that they
were installed for a reason at some
point yeah yeah one of the strategies or
techniques that you that you talk about
is Five Finger you're breathing mhm
explain I love this so this gets super
pragmatic and I love this because this
is something for any any parent that has
a a young child they can teach it to
their kid and if the parent is stressed
out or
distraught these loving kids just want
to help their parents and so they can
say hey when I seem stressed come and
walk me through this five finger
breathing and the way it works is very
simple so you know you take one hand
take the index finger of one hand put at
the base of the pinky of the other hand
and as we breathe in we're going to
trace up the finger and pay attention so
I'm I'll just do
this you want to do it with me mhm you
pause at the top of your pinky and then
you breathe out as you trace down the
inside of the pinky and then as you
breathe in you trace up your ring
finger pause and then breathe out down
the inside of the ring
finger do two more breathe in Trace up
the middle
finger breathe out Trace down
breathe in Trace up the index
finger breathe out Trace down okay one
more up the
thumb and then down so that was five
breaths I did a little fast but we could
do it at our own natural breathing Pace
how's that feel just to take five
mindful breaths it's amazing how
something as simple as that can really
calm you down yeah I'm want to geek out
about the science about this because I
love this so our dors prefrontal cortex
working memory right we can only hold a
few pieces of information in our working
memory at one time right the grocery
list can't be very long or we'll forget
it and it's probably somewhere around
four pieces of information so how do you
clear out that cache well you pay
attention to four things that aren't the
worrying mind the worrying thoughts the
feeling anxious the whatever so we paid
attention to two physical Sensations
actually three physical Sensations two
fingers and the breathing and we watched
our so there's we've just paid attention
to four things and that clears that cash
out and as you said we calm the
physiology down in as few as five
breaths and then so if the worry or the
stress thought comes back in it there's
a mismatch from an emotional tone level
where our brain says hey you should be
stressed and our body's like no not
feeling it and so it's much easier to
notice those thoughts and just oh
there's a thought and note it let it go
because our body is grounded in you know
in a calmer physiology I like how simple
it is uh would this be something that
would be good as somebody who has a
tendency to eat more than I should to do
right before I have my meal absolutely
yeah and you can also do it if you're
noticing like you're you're racing
through your meal take five breaths it
only takes five breaths and see what
happens see if that helps because it
also you might have noticed it like
helps heighten the senses cuz we're
grounded and that awareness kind of pops
a little bit more yeah I like it I just
like how practical and simple it is it's
like oh I'll just do the five finger
breathing yeah like I can do that yeah
it's not a big deal it's not how does
all of this play into treating somebody
who has an eating disorder well for
example the hunger CIT was not written
for people with anorexia nervosa that is
a really severe clinical condition that
requires a village and so I actually
give some resources in the introduction
saying hey if you've got anorexia Noosa
or have a family member and you're
reading this because you want to help
here are some resources go to those
resources so this book is not for that
and believe me I would say is also along
those lines but for somebody with
bingeing disorder I've seen this be very
very helpful for people and I've treated
a lot of patients in my clinic with
binging
disorder so how does one know if
they're somebody who's just a binge
eater versus somebody who might need
treatment for disordered eating well
depends more clinical yeah it depends on
how much you believe in the DSM so as a
board certified psychiatrist you know
that's the Bible that I was trained on I
think that that is an evolving uh
document so it was first developed as a
billing document sure what are we on
seven now six what uh we're on five but
you know by definition evolving but
slowly very slowly so I like to think of
the person and not the book that you
know that we try to you know pigeon hole
people into diagnosis around so the
pragmatic thing is how much is somebody
suffering if it's something that's
really getting in the way of their daily
life and they're just really debilitated
by it that might be a sign that it's
helpful to go see a professional and
these things can be done in conjunction
if they want to really kind of learn how
the brain works and work with their
brain you know that's why I wrote this
book is so they can start to get a lay
of the Land
There I would
imagine that somebody who
really takes everything that you're
sharing
seriously incorporates it into their
life goes on this journey with
mindfulness meditation developing a
sense of present awareness with their
behaviors Etc this is going
to clearly reshape their relationship
with food but I mean this spills over
into
everything so what has your experience
been with with patients that you've
taken through some version of this
protocol when they come out the other
side or a year later what does their
life look like what's changed what
hasn't this is the gift that keeps on
giving and I like eating as a very
practical example because we all have to
eat and so if we can use that eating as
a vehicle to learn how our mind works
and learn how to start working with our
mind we then start generalizing that
knowledge to apply it to other things
and that to me is is a marker of the
development of wisdom so we become wise
and we start to see oh well I'm in the
habit of being um snarky with my with my
partner oh well let me apply these three
steps there oh well it's it doesn't go
that well when I'm snarky and it goes
better when I'm kind oh let me lean into
the kindness piece right and that's just
one example of where we can start I see
this start to generalize into people's
lives because we're treating the whole
human here we just start with that
eating as that door in and then you we
start filling the house right if you
start exercising compassion to
yourself and you earn self-esteem by
performing esteemable acts on behalf of
yourself then you are going to interface
with the world differently treat others
differently they will then treat you
different
your relationship not just with food but
with literally everything will change
and then maybe they start treating other
people differently and then those people
start treating other people differently
you're changing the world Jud well I
don't know about that but I love to see
the possibility of this change starting
one person at a time and then spreading
compassion through social contagion this
is the real agenda this is the real goal
here of course the the human mind wants
to identify the simple easy stuff
whether it's deleting this macro from
your plate or this new fat diet that's
all shiny over here the latest of which
is OIC right weight loss drugs I don't
really have to think about this let
alone be present or mindful in my
behavior I can just take this drug and
it will take care of it this was all the
rage about a year ago we're how long are
we into sort of live Human Experience
with this brand new drug at this point
the short answer is not not long enough
yeah so what are you seeing I'm sure
you've had patients that have wanted it
have experienced it what's going on here
well it's been really fascinating to
observe with my patients and so I I'm
thinking of one patient in particular
who had clinical obesity and also
alcohol use disorder and so she started
taking OB zumic to help with her weight
and for about 4 months she she was like
this is a miracle you know like I'm just
not hungry cuz she was nausea a lot you
know and so she lost a bunch of weight
and she's like you know what else I just
don't have cravings for alcohol anymore
yeah and so and this is not just a case
n of one it's case studies in the
literature and there are studies that
are ongoing now around like this helping
people with substance use problem with
her was that it it worked for about four
months and then she's like Doc it's like
it just stopped working and she was
totally baffled I was too I was like
well you know they're saying that you
should be on these drugs for life which
is great marketing for the drug company
but it can't be shocking that somebody
develops a tolerance and it doesn't work
anymore yeah I mean our one thing that
we know for certain is that our brains
are really good at adapting and so if
you give our brain a challenge it's
going to challenge that challenge right
back and so I don't know what's going on
I don't know what percentage of people
you know this is happening to but I do
know this if if we we rely on the magic
pills and the Magic Bullets and the
magic
injections we're never going to get at
piece with ourselves and develop that
self-efficacy that's critical for
everything are there negative side
effects that you've seen as well oh yeah
and some of those negative side
effects liver toxicity or something like
that I don't know or kidney there so
there are some of those things that
aren't I haven't seen a ton of those
things I mean the the typical effects or
you know GI distress things like that
sometimes vomiting but one thing that uh
that people haven't talked in my opinion
enough about is like a lot of this
weight loss is coming because people are
losing muscle
mass that's not great if your visceral
fat stays constant but your scale number
is different because you've declined in
your yeah that's not good well they're
probably losing that visceral fat as
well but they're also like the ideal one
in this highlights how even though this
is much farther along than any other
drug that I've seen still not a deal
there are some studies that are
suggesting that it's helping with heart
conditions things like that but all of
those are obesity related so it makes
sense MH so they're probably helping
that visceral adiposity and things like
that but you don't want to be losing
muscle mass you actually want to be
building muscle mass as you're starting
to exercise so if people are like I'm
just going to sit on the couch and
inject myself with this glp1 drug that's
a problem because they're not learning
to work with their minds so if the
things stop working for them or if they
you if they stop getting coverage and
this is you know mind you just the
people that can afford it or have
insurance that helps you know so for
everybody else for some people
medication is can to be helpful for
everyone learning how to work with their
mind is essential well said what is your
feeling
around technology and apps and how they
can be helpful or not helpful to
somebody who's trying to Dev develop a
new relationship with food well some of
the ones that I've seen that aren't so
helpful and this is the Mr Duffy problem
is the the tracking apps where somebody
says I'm just going to track my food and
then I'm going to magically you know
lose weight or be successful now I've
certainly known people that the tracking
has helped them become aware of what
they're eating right and so they'll take
a picture and then now they're more
aware so again that's getting back to
the awareness aspect and in that sense
great if that's a a helpful tool think
of as a training wheel that helps
somebody become more aware that's very
helpful but if somebody's relying on a
tracking app to count their calories and
their caloric intake these things are
notoriously
inaccurate and they're relying on an app
to tell them when they're hungry as
we've just discussed that's a big
problem I'm just thinking about in the
same way that billions of dollars are
poured into ultr processed foods to make
them irresistible similarly you know
hundreds of billions of dollars have
gone into these apps to kind of gamify
and addict us into scrolling endlessly
but there's something about the
gamification of habit change in the form
of these apps that I think has some
value but it's in your relationship and
how you're kind of holding these things
like I'm wearing a whoop and it tells me
my sleep score and I don't put a lot of
stock into these scores but I do look at
Trends and even if it's inaccurate and
its data points like over a period of a
month or whatever I notice well I sleep
better if I don't eat too late at night
or whatever I can like map on it can be
a tool for mindful awareness that
connects the behavior with the results
yeah and I think you're highlighting
something really important which is if
we can't be aware of something then we
can't we can't get that feedback you
know the positive or negative feedback
and so this is where I think humans in
technology can work very well together
if we're very careful about how we do it
and so for example something like a
whoop where you can notice a trend over
time that there's no way that you'd be
able to uh just individually be able to
say oh five days later it was because of
this where as you can start to see those
trend lines and you're like hey there's
something off here I wouldn't have known
that because it's too subtle for me to
see very helpful so I'm not
anti-technology in this respect I think
technology can be extremely helpful what
about the accountability piece um I'm
interested in in how you think about the
importance of holding yourself
accountable not only to yourself but
perhaps to somebody else for both
positive and negative
reinforcement but at the same time maybe
that pushes us into that willpower Loop
that we're trying to extract ourselves
from that's a good question I hadn't
thought about the linking The Willpower
piece to this so let's just walk through
this in real time so the accountability
piece a connection with somebody else
can be really powerful and so if
somebody is bearing witness in a kind
supportive way that can help help us
when we feel like we're just treading
water and so the accountability piece
can be really helpful when we we feel
like oh man I'm just really struggling
here it kind of injects some energy into
the equation not necessarily willpower
but it can help in a in a very
productive
way on the other hand if we become
dependent upon that you know it's like
oh every time I have a crav I have to
call my sponsor what happens when they
don't pick up the phone so I think of
this as a both and we can have that
support and ultimately we want to
develop the
internal mechanism like that internal
support as well that's why I brought it
up because success long term is going to
be driven by your internal barometer and
I think accountability is important in
leading you towards that but at some
point you have to kind of transcend that
yeah right and that other person to whom
you're holding yourself accountable does
sort of feel a little bit like The
Willpower thing like I'm just going to
do this because I want this guy to
approve of me and so I'm going to grit
it out until I get to that 30-day point
and you you're not really owning this
journey for yourself yeah and you can
also see that could be the willpower
story that's saying hey it's rewarding
to get this person's approval so you
could also see that from a reinforcement
learning standpoint which maybe a little
more accurate as we begin to wind this
down I think it's revelatory for people
to understand the limitations of
willpower in the context of changing
eating habits I mean that's just like a
mindblower I think and it will be for a
lot of people what else do you think
think people get fundamentally wrong in
their approach to trying to uplevel
their habits around food it's a good
question because 95% of it is willpower
is the willpower piece I just that's
such a dominant Paradigm I'm just trying
to think if there's anything else that's
even remotely a second it's not a close
second well the temporal nature of
dieting is related to willpower right
because it's like I'm holding on tight
until I can release right and then you
always you know revert back to your old
Behavior patterns and the holding on
tight is until we can't hold on anymore
because we're exhausted and then we
slide again so yeah I honestly can't
think of anything that's substantive
besides the willpower when it's so
dominant the book is great I think it's
going to help a lot of people yeah I
think you did a wonderful job and like I
said it is a a natural progression of
the work that that you're doing and I
think what's so kind of wonderful and
beautiful about who you are and how you
comport yourself in the world and and
share your wisdom is this interesting
blend of West in East like you are
deeply informed by Eastern traditions
and have been personally impacted by
your experiences in meditation and the
various teachers that you've worked with
and written books with Etc but you weave
it so indelibly with the hard science
that makes it accessible to a western
audience
which is another kind of Trojan horse
that's happening here right like you're
really trying to create this Inception
where you can introduce these Arcane
Eastern ideas to a western Audience by
draping it in
Neuroscience yeah some people describe
science is like the Western the new
religion in the west you because people
believe it because it's got a picture of
a brain or something like that so from a
way to be pragmatically helpful you know
if if that helps people believe things
great also I would say science in itself
is useful because you can see if
something works or it doesn't sure um
well you're a change agent you're
activating change and a lot of people
positive change and the kind of question
that I like to ask change agents at the
at the end of of these podcasts is is
more of a a bird's eyee view or kind of
a 10,000 foot perspective on the nature
of change and the human
capacity to change because I think a lot
of people feel trapped in their habits
or they feel like they can be inspired
by hearing or bearing witness to
somebody else's story of transformation
but they have difficulty connecting it
with their own capacity for change
within themselves so maybe leave us with
a few thoughts about that capacity that
I think lives in lurks within all of us
well I would say that I am more and more
in inspired the more I work with people
and see this happen in even very extreme
cases and that inspiration comes from
people taking that leap of faith where
they see somebody else you know make a
major change in their life they're
inspired but more importantly I think of
this as developing evidence-based Faith
where they take that first step and
they're like oh this isn't so bad the
ground is solid they take the Second
Step they take the third step they build
the momentum
and then they see in their own life for
themselves in their own experience that
this is possible and that is the most
inspirational Faith ever it's unshakable
because it's your own
experience beautiful take the first step
people you can't go on the journey
unless you take that first step
absolutely right thank you you're always
welcome here uh I really enjoyed that I
appreciate it everybody please go pick
up the hunger habit available every
where it will change how you think about
not just your relationship with food but
all of your behaviors that you find
might be compulsive in nature from time
to time which I think is what it is to
be human yeah well said thanks Ben uh if
people want to learn more about you is
it just Dr jud.com where's the best
place for them to yep Dr jud.com
cool all right man appreciate you thank
you yeah thank you cheers
peace
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newslet which you can find on the footer
of any page at Rich roll.com Today's
show was produced and engineered by
Jason Cameo with digal audio engineering
by Kale Curtis the video edition of the
podcast was created by Blake Curtis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Davey Greenberg
graphic and social media media assets
courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you Georgia
Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt Trapper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plance
[Music]
namaste
he